dear Mathilde it's been three months
since the incident and I can't take life
in this bunker anymore the specter of
certain death is not so horrific as the
knowledge that I will never again know
your touch today's the day I emerge face
what's out there
[Music]
hey guys I'm Brent Rose writer and
bearded bag boy and today we're talking
about go bags aka bug-out bags or
emergency preparedness kits basically
therefore when the hits the fan and
you need to GTFO ASAP now it could be
any type of emergency situation from
earthquake flood or fire to zombie
apocalypse and collapse of society or
maybe our president leads us to nuclear
war because somebody made fun of them on
Twitter the point is to be covered in
pretty much any situation now these kits
cost a lot of money to put together and
it seems crazy to me to spend that much
cash on something you hope you'll never
have to use that's why my personal bug
out bag doubles as a really solid
camping and backpacking kit not only do
you get to use this stuff for fun and
adventure but it also ensures that
you've practiced using it all before so
if you're ever faced with a really dire
situation you're not struggling trying
to figure it out for the first time but
I've put a lot of time and thought into
this to include everything you need
nothing you don't and you should be
covered for just about any situation now
let's get to it to start off the most
essential part of a go bag is the bag
itself because you're likely to be on
foot and walking over uncertain terrain
I think you should go with a backpack
setup and personally I recommend the
Gregory Baltar Oh 75 to 75 liter pack
which means we've got plenty of room for
everything we're going to recommend you
carry and it's built to carry weight and
not kill your body
is really excellent hip pads and
suspension system it also has a zip off
date pack and plenty of small pockets to
organize your gear now if you're a
smaller person you might want to go with
a 65 liter pack and if you're carrying
more stuff like for a child you might
want to go with something around 85 or
90 liters let's talk about shelter for
most people I recommend going with a
real tent it offers a little more
protection from the elements and a
little bit of privacy which could be
very nice an emergency situation for the
majority of people I recommend the REI
Half Dome - plus it's nice and compact
it's light enough it's certainly well
priced and it gives you a good amount of
headroom and storage space it's just a
really solid all-around tent in an
emergency situation every little bit of
sleep is really going to count that's
why you want to be comfortable but you
don't want to carry too much weight for
that reason I recommend the therm-a-rest
NeoAir all season sv
it's incredibly compacting rolled up it
gives you enough padding even for side
sleepers it gives you plenty of
insulation from a cold ground and it
inflates super super quickly it's
awesome
sleeping bags now my absolute favorite
is the Marmot plasma 30 it's super super
compact really light and very warm it's
also stupid expensive so for most people
I recommend going with the Kelty cosmic
down 20 it's actually a little bit
warmer just a bit bigger and heavier
both of them are really nice bags though
did you know that humans need to drink
water to survive it's true which is why
in a disaster situation finding clean
drinking water is one of the number-one
priorities the gold standard for
cleaning water is the MSR Guardian
filter it's got a high flow rate it's
strong and fields repairable and it can
filter out everything your standard
water filter does but what really sets
it apart is it can also filter out
viruses if a mutated zombie virus is
you're a doomsday scenario of choice
this is the one you want
now if the Guardian is too expensive and
you're not concerned about viruses you
can go with something lighter and
cheaper like the vapor micro filter
simply fill up your bag of water screw
in the filter and it's ready to drink
it's recommended that you carry at least
three litres of water per person per day
my favorite way to do that is the
platypus big zip LP this is the 3 liter
version which gets you all of your water
in one place it also fits in the
hydration pouch in the backpack which
means you can just sip as you're fleeing
for safety as a backup
I also recommend carrying a straight up
wide mouth 32-ounce and algae and bottle
it's made of tough lexan so it's not
going to break easily
it's got clear markings right on the
side and it can also carry hot liquids
as a bonus it screws right into the MSR
Guardian for easy Phillip now every bug
out bag should have at least three days
worth of food in it that could be
something as cheap and simple as dried
beans and rice or if you want to save a
little bit more weight and don't mind
spending the extra money
I'd go with freeze-dried meals rip open
the top add boiling water you've got a
pretty tasty well-balanced meal but how
are you going to boil all that water
personally I like the MSR alpinists 2
it's a really basic cookware set you've
got two insulated mugs two saucers to
eat off of and a pot with a strainer lid
add in a couple of these metals
to sum up sports and you and your
apocalypse sweetie are good to go for
stoves my all-time favorite is the tried
and trusted MSR dragonfly it's
especially good for apocalypse scenarios
because it can burn almost any kind of
fuel everything from white gas to
regular old gasoline
unlike other liquid fuel stoves this one
can actually simmer just because
everyone you've ever loved is dead
doesn't mean you should put up with
burnt pancakes how you're gonna light
that stove but we recommend you have at
least three different ways to light a
fire now
easiest just your simple straight up bic
lighter storm proof matches these things
are windproof and waterproof and believe
me they will not go out on you and for
the longer-term solution I like this
magnesium bar with striker basically you
use your knife to shave off some
magnesium powder and then make a big-ass
spark now let's talk about those knives
you need them for all the obvious
reasons I really like this goober knife
because not only is it super sharp it's
got a full tang handle so you can use
the back for breaking glass if you need
to
that's it if you want to go something
cheaper I really love my Mora knife it's
super strong really sharp and I only
paid about 12 bucks for
so what to the end of the world there's
a very good chance the grid is going to
go down which means there are no lights
so for that reason we recommend you
carry at least two forms of light for
headlamps I really like the Princeton
tech sync it has a ton of different
modes but unlike a lot of other
headlamps you don't have to memorize
some sequence of button pushes just has
a simple dial that changes the mode on
as a backup I like the Mini Maglite LED
small enough to fit in any pocket and
it's really bright the LED will also
make sure it lasts a good long time
there's one other flashlight that I
really like carrying and that's the
Viper tech VTS 195 it's your chargeable
it's got a really bright light and it
does one other rather cool trick that's
the sound of 38 million volts coursing
through these two contacts and it really
really hurts
trust me mother oh and that brings us to
our most controversial topic self
defense
now there are a lot of people who
believe you absolutely must have a gun
in your go-bag personally it's not my
thing but I totally get it if you want
it do what you got to do between my
knives and my stun gun I generally feel
pretty well protected but I also like to
carry a slingshot not only can you hurt
somebody from far away if you need to
but you can also hunt small game if
you're really in a bind also great for
catching food a telescoping fishing rod
this is an eight-foot mako hurricane rod
slap a cheap Shimano reel on there and
you're ready to catch something so let's
talk about generating heat you need to
be able to get firewood I really like
the Gerber survival hatchet not only is
it super hard and really sharp it also
has a back end you can use as a hammer
it's a really nice piece of kit
alternatively if you've got something
bigger to cut down take a look at the
Sabre cut saw it's basically a chain saw
where your body is the motor you wrap it
around a dead tree branch or tree trunk
and just let your arms do their thing
you'll definitely burn some calories
doing it but not as many as you would if
you're cutting down the whole tree with
that little hatchet we can't talk about
tools without bringing up the multi-tool
my personal favorite is the Leatherman
Wave it's got 17 tools in one but it
fits nicely in the palm of your hand
it's got everything from screwdrivers to
scissors and knives so when you're in an
emergency situation take it out of your
backpack and just leave it right in your
pocket
being that it's the apocalypse the
chances are good that you're going to
hurt yourself at some point which is why
it's good to have a first aid kit this
is the REI backpacker multi-day it's got
enough stuff for four people for five
days but you can always add your own
things to it I personally like to add a
little bottle of hydrogen peroxide and
the all-important toenail clippers also
make extra certain that you have a
backup supply of any medications you
take regulated there's something you
need to survive make sure you have some
in the bag one of the most powerful
tools in your arsenal is your phone if
the grid is still up obviously you can
use it to communicate and download
information that said you want to be
prepared in case the grid goes down
which means you need to download a few
apps now there's backcountry navigator
topo GPS for Android or gaia gps for iOS
both of them will let you download maps
offline another app I really like from
both systems is the SAS survival app it
has tons and tons of information on how
to survive in many different types of
situations and it doesn't take up the
bulk of a full book in your backpack you
can also use the regular old Google Maps
app download your whole home area so
even if the grid goes down you can find
your way out of the city for portable
battery I really like the Anchor Power
Core Plus this is the thirteen thousand
four hundred milliamp version that's
enough to recharge your iphone seven six
times
it's really really power dense and it
charges fast but how do you keep this
thing charged well use the power of the
Sun for solar panels I really like the
gold 0 Nomad 7 plus it's super compact
very lightweight you just attach it to
the outside of your backpack and I'll be
putting 7 watts of power into your
battery as you hike you really don't
want to have to rely on your phone for
navigation though make sure you have a
detailed map of the region you live in
and make sure you know how to use a
compass this is the Brunton through arc
5 it's a cheap and simple compass it's
got a nice little magnifier and it's got
adjustable to clinching don't wait until
an emergency situation to try to learn
how to use a map and compass though go
out into the woods and practice two of
your most valuable utility items would
be paracord
and duct tape now paracord is basically
just your super strong thin lightweight
cord but you can use it for repairing
things for rescuing somebody for making
a splint definitely something you need
in your case as far as duct tape goes
I'd go with Gorilla Tape it's just a lot
stronger it's a lot stickier if it's
going to
last you longer let's get into the
miscellaneous but mandatory this is the
pack towel personal super super compact
yet highly absorbent and very soft and
comforting this is the midland compact
emergency crank radio also has a
flashlight sun block bug spray
hand sanitizer multipurpose soap a
travel toothbrush and last but not least
birth control do you really want another
mouth to feed in the apocalypse at least
two sets of spare batteries emergency
contact phone numbers written out on
paper sunglasses
toilet paper and a lightweight plastic
trowel to bury them one of those
important survival tools you can have
with you is cash money personally i say
500 bucks is a pretty good amount but
it's really all about what you think
you're gonna need then again money might
be obsolete
so whatever now let's talk clothes the
basic rule is you want to layer you need
an insulating layer a rain proof layer a
hat for warmth and for shaded some
strong sturdy hiking boots and you want
some thick hiking socks in terms of
materials avoid cotton because of the
way it absorbs and retains water and
instead go with wool or some sort of
synthetic fabric which will keep you
warm even when moist make sure you have
enough for at least a few days and don't
forget that thong thong thong so what
did we learn here today while a kit like
this doesn't come cheap not only do you
have everything you need to survive a
really bad situation you've got
everything you need to have a really
great time in one of our many amazing
national parks also scale to the size of
your crew if it's just you your going to
need less if you have a family of seven
you're going to want to divide up the
way depending on each person's carrying
ability these are my personal favorites
but what do you think is there something
I'm missing let us know in the comments
below subscribe to Wired if you haven't
already with all that being said there's
really only one thing left to do
dear Matilda today's the day I emerge
face what's out there I love you
Brett
[Music]
hi